So, oh ich bin viel zu laut, lull, so, äh, bei mir ist der Stream gerade schwarz,
der Stream sollte nicht schwarz sein, ich glaube da stimmt mit meinem Browser was nicht,
falls schon irgendjemand da ist, ist der Stream bei euch schwarz,
ne, ok funktioniert, funktioniert, easy, easy clap, so jetzt müssen wir wahrscheinlich erstmal
wieder nervig das Bild einstellen, wobei ne, es funktioniert, yeah, gut,
da kann ich ja mal meine Vorschau ausmachen, der Game Sound ist ein bisschen leise,
so Leute, entspannte Runde Plants vs. Zombies spielen, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt oder
wenn ihr irgendwelche Themen habt, schreibt einfach in den Chat, dass ich ein bisschen was
zu labern hab, ist die Game Lautstärke ok, passt das, welcher Game Sound,
hört man nix, man sollte jetzt eigentlich was hören, ok, oh mein Virenscanner will sich
aktualisieren, das ist ja exakt der richtige Zeitpunkt jetzt, das hätte keinen besseren
Zeitpunkt geben können, jetzt hab ich gar nicht geguckt, war hier noch Pool Level, ich
glaub hier war noch Pool Level, war noch Pool Level, ja ich glaub, fuck ich weiß, ich hab
jetzt nicht geguckt, lol, ok ist auf jeden Fall Nacht Level, ich muss doch mal gucken,
ich muss mal gucken, was für ein Level, fuck was haben wir für ein Level, können wir schon
irgendwas kaufen, nee noch nicht, ja Pool Level bei Nacht, ok, Pilz, Pilz, Pilz, Pilz,
das da, ich muss mich selbst noch ein bisschen leiser machen, was denn hier los, ich find
das immer geil, dass Windows einfach, obwohl du nichts gemacht hast, umstellt irgendwie,
ich versteh das bis heute nicht, warum es das macht, das brauchen wir, oh die Maus ist
ja so schwammig in dem Game, das brauchen wir und das brauchen wir, so und ansonsten
keine Ahnung, mal gucken, ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Tage nicht mehr gespielt, ich weiß
gar nicht mehr, was ich genau mache, sowas hier wär vielleicht mal nicht schlecht und
immer den noch, ich hoffe ich hab nichts vergessen, ja Leute, wenn es irgendwas gibt, was euch
so unter den Fingern brennt, was ihr mal fragen wolltet oder irgendwas in der Richtung, ah
fuck wir haben Nebel, das hab ich dann richtig geguckt, es ist ja Nebel, dann brauch ich
die Dinger hier noch, ok, Pilz, Pilz, das Ding brauch ich, das Ding brauch ich, das Ding
brauch ich, das da, das da, das da, so jetzt haben wir nämlich auch alles voll, wir sind
fast durch, wir müssen fast durch sein, also zumindest können es nicht mehr all zu viele
Level sein, danach kommt noch das Dach und dann ist fertig, ja danach kommt nur noch Dach,
genau, die Maus ist so schwammig in dem Game, oh ich muss mal kurz was gucken auf dem zweiten
Schirm, ob hier Encoding noch läuft, ja funktioniert auch alles, plupp, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
plupp, hast du die Nintendo Direct letzte Woche gesehen, ja was sagst du dazu, nee hab
ich nicht, war irgendwas interessantes, habt ihr die geguckt, also ich hab die Nintendo
Direct nicht geguckt, wahrscheinlich, wenn ich raten müsste, wenn ich raten müsste weitere
Wii U Umsetzungen, das könnten doch sein, das war überlegen, ich meine es ist Nintendo,
weitere Wii U Umsetzungen und was könnten sie mal neues, neues Metroid oder so was vielleicht
mal, keine Ahnung, was gab es denn, erzählt mal Leute, was gab es denn auf der Nintendo
Direct, bestimmt wieder noch so, bestimmt ein Animal Crossing, also Animal Crossing
muss sein, hab ich irgendwie das Gefühl, ich weiß zwar nicht, was alle an der Reihe so
toll finden, aber ich finde ja das Animal Crossing geil, Brains, so, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, online, used During Warhammer,C judgment,
Piss dich, alter!
Wird helfen?
Ah gut, werde ich jetzt noch dauern.
De de de de de de de
Ich gucke gleich in den Chat, soll ich wegpusten?
Das habe ich übrigens viel zu weit vorne hingesetzt, fällt mir gerade auf, bin bescheuert.
So, wenn er das hier frisst, dann kommt die Nuss hin.
Ich bin noch irgendwie ein bisschen im Arsch, kann sein, sorry, wenn ich ein bisschen langsam bin mit Chatlesen heute.
Letzte Welle schon, okay.
Oh.
Gut, hier mal gucken, die Level sind aber auch immer so kurz.
Alter, Donation jetzt schon.
Ich gucke gleich, Leute, ich gucke gleich.
Das können wir eigentlich gar nicht mehr verlieren, weil wir haben noch volle Reihe Rasen mehr.
Easy, kann ich jetzt mal Chat lesen.
Sebaro, mir fällt gerade einer Stange nicht mehr Donaten ab, danke.
Wie gesagt, muss ich keiner irgendwie gezwungen fühlen zu donaten oder sowas.
Eigentlich haben wir schon gewonnen, das war ja easy.
Ich habe überhaupt nicht richtig geguckt, easy win, schreckt.
So, was kam denn jetzt bei Nintendo direkt raus?
Zeig mal, was habt ihr, habt ihr irgendwas geschrieben?
Nichts spannendes, nur Wii U Ports und DLC.
Ja, Wii U Ports wundert mich nicht.
Sebaro hat noch geschrieben, noch mal zu deinem Riot Band Video.
In der Einschule, die ich betreue, wird es bald ein Vodafone Kabelanschluss mit 400 oder 500 MBit down und 25-20 MBit abgeben.
Dank mir, äh, dank dir geben.
Was haben sie denn jetzt?
Oh, Fliegezombies, da müssen wir jetzt aufpassen, mal mal Kaktus, Kaktusstelz.
Kaktusstelz, Beste.
Ähm, ja, aber mal Kaktusstelz, würde ich sagen.
Kaktusstelz.
Oh, ich sehe gerade aus dem Augenwinkel, da ist was ganz langes Rotes im Chat.
Also, Wall of Taxi, ich guck gleich.
Hi Max, ich schaffe mein Infostudium anscheinend nicht und in drei Wochen habe ich meinen letzten, was meinen dritten Versuch.
Kann halt sein, dass ich es nicht schaffe.
Aber ich habe große Angst um meine Zukunft, meine Eltern und Freunde werden sehr enttäuscht sein.
Meine Eltern sagen immer, dass Ausbildungen nicht so gut sind wie Studium, sonst würde ich Info-Ausbildung machen.
Ähm, ja, ich, also, ich, wo ist dann das Problem?
Also, warum kriegst du, warum denkst du denn, dass du das nicht schaffst?
Also, ich mein, drei Wochen sind jetzt halt auch nicht mehr so die lange Zeit da großartig was zu machen.
Der 16K, der ist ja super.
Wie, die haben die, ernsthaft, die haben die ganze Schule über 16, über DSL 16.000 laufen?
Das ist aber scheiße.
Das ist aber echt schlecht, dass jetzt jetzt, dass da überhaupt noch einer arbeiten kann.
Mathe ist so schwer, erst ein Teil mal zu faul bin, effektiv zu lernen.
Ja, das, also, mit Mathe haben die meisten Informatik-Studenten ja das Problem.
Also, wenn es irgendwo daran scheitert, dann oftmals an Mathe.
Ähm, ich mein, nachdem du jetzt ja noch schon ein paar Mal Prüfung gemacht hast,
oder versucht hast, wo lag's denn bei den letzten Prüfungen dran?
Ich mein, vielleicht kannst du dir irgendwas gezielt angucken.
Ansonsten hab ich dir ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie die Regeln sind,
ob man jetzt einfach sagen kann, man macht jetzt nicht die Prüfung gleich
und besucht auch ein paar Vorlesungen oder so, keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Pilz.
So, jetzt komm, hier kommen jetzt Nüsse hin.
Das hier hält eigentlich erst mal ganz gut.
Zack, sichern wir erst mal den Kram ab.
Oh fuck, wir brauchen ja Kaktus, wir müssen Kaktus bauen.
Ganz, ganz vergessen, wir müssen Kaktus bauen, kommen ja Fliege-Zombies an Start.
Kaktusse müssen da hin.
Eigentlich müssen wir gar keine Kaktusse bauen, wir haben nämlich das Blatt.
Mit dem Blatt kann man die Zombies auch einfach wegwehen.
Was eh viel besser ist.
Bauen jetzt einfach mal blind da vorne das Zeug hin.
Aber wir sollten schon Runde Kaktus bauen,
einfach weil die Kackpilze da hinten nicht vorne nicht hinkommen, die Kleinen.
Das Spiel, sag mal Leute, wie findest du, ich find das Spiel ist super entspannend.
Das Spiel ist super entspannend irgendwie.
Es ist jetzt auch nicht sonderlich schwer oder so.
Es ist einfach entspannend.
Es ist jetzt nicht total Resident Sleeper, dass man quasi das im Schlaf spielen könnte oder so.
Aber es ist einfach genug.
Ich find das super entspannend.
Jetzt gleich den Chat, die Runde ist ja gleich vorbei.
Auf Liege-Zombies an Start.
Mal gucken, dass wir vielleicht die obere Reihe noch einen hinkriegen.
Ups, verklickt.
Der Kaktus-Flick hat nicht funktioniert.
So, in der Mitte haben wir das alles schon ganz gut abgesichert.
Ich bin gerade nicht so multitaskingfähig, jetzt noch Chat zu gucken.
So, wir haben eigentlich alles ausgebaut, mehr müssen wir nicht machen.
Wir können jetzt ein bisschen Sonnen sammeln und einfach warten.
Da sieht ja nichts.
Wo machen wir denn Nuss noch hin?
Unten fehlt jetzt noch eine Nuss, den Rest können wir noch ein paar Kaktus bauen.
Eigentlich, easy win, easy clap.
Man kann übrigens anstatt den Kaktus zu leben auch mit diesem Platz die Viecher wegpusten.
Ja, richtig geiles Game.
Das beste RPG 2017.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, mit was für einem kleinen Studio das gekommen ist, ist das der Wahnsinn.
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, was wir da auf die Reihe gekriegt haben.
Wir können sich alle mal eine Scheibe abschneiden.
Habe ich mit einer Informatikausbildung die gleichen Berufschancen wie wenn du Informatik studiert hast?
Naja, nicht unbedingt. Es kommt halt auf den Laden an, wo man landet.
Wenn einer jetzt explizit nach jemanden sucht, der Informatik studiert hat oder einen Abschluss hat,
dann sucht er ja halt erstmal einen.
Das ist dann schwierig ihm das auszureden.
Und es gibt auch ein paar Sachen wo, sag mal so, wenn du eine Ausbildung hast in diesem Bereich,
gibt es ja im Prinzip noch Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration oder Anwendungsentwicklung oder sowas,
also es gibt schon ein paar Sachen, halt die ganzen theoretischen Grundlagen,
die du mit einem Studium hast, die du mit einer Ausbildung einfach nicht hast.
Halt gerade das, was dich nervt, dieser ganze Mathe-Teil, das hast du in der Ausbildung nicht.
Die Leute, die Ausbildung machen, haben schlicht ergreifend einfach keinen Plan von solchen Sachen.
Also zumindest nicht von dem, was vermittelt wird in der Ausbildung.
Das kommt da ziemlich kurz an, weil man da jetzt in irgendeinem Bereich, in der Forschung oder,
keine Ahnung, mir fällt jetzt kein gescheites Beispiel an.
Also manchmal ist das schon halt schlecht, wenn du wirklich Leute hast, die auch wissen,
wie die Grundlagen funktionieren.
In täglichen Sachen, wie wenn du in irgendeinem Team bist, die eine Anwendung programmieren,
betreuen oder sonst was in der Richtung, da macht es jetzt nicht so den großen Unterschied.
Da kommt es eher auf die praktische Erfahrung an, die du natürlich mit einer Ausbildung
in der Regel mehr hast als mit einem reinen Studium.
Das kann man aber nicht so pauschal sagen.
Also im Durchschnitt bin ich mir relativ sicher, wenn man in irgendeine Statistik guckt,
dass wahrscheinlich die Gehälter im Durchschnitt, die Gehälter von Leuten, die studiert haben,
höher als Leute, die nicht studiert haben.
Das ist halt so.
Das sagt jetzt über den Einzelfall nicht viel aus, aber im Durchschnitt.
Und es ist einfach wichtig, dass man sich in irgendeinem Bereich gut auskennt,
dass man sich in einem Bereich gut auskennt, der einen interessiert und vor allem,
dass es halt nicht so ein 0815-Bereich ist, wo jeder rumhampelt.
Also ich will nicht wissen, wie viele Windows-Admins es gibt.
Es gibt mehr Windows-Admins, die eigentlich auch nicht mehr machen können,
als so die standard 3 Sachen anklicken und davon gibt es halt hunderttausende irgendwie.
So viele brauchst du nicht.
Moin, Splitty.
So, ich muss mal kurz chat scrollsorn.
Der Nielson ist auch da, moin.
Servus, Max. Grüße aus der Nachbarstadt. Kaufst du aus Offenbach?
Naja, Bot-Hangmann oder Bot-Hangmann-Soter-Wahnsinn ist das jetzt auch nicht.
Also damit kann man schon gut leben, ja.
Aber so extrem viel, es sind 1800 nach dem du steuern und gerade bezahlt hast, jetzt auch nicht.
Aha, Scharfenburg, okay, ist auch nicht weit weg, das stimmt.
Kommt da, aber ich muss dazu sagen, ich hab das jetzt zu allgemein gesagt, ja.
Es kommt immer auf die Region an, wo man herkommt.
Es gibt Regionen, da sind 1800 bzw. 2700, was er geschrieben hat, schon ziemlich viel.
Jetzt in Frankfurt nicht unbedingt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich Ausbildungssystemintegration oder Anwendungsentwicklung machen will.
Ganz ehrlich, nimm das, wo dir der Betrieb besser gefällt.
Du kannst nach beiden Sachen suchen.
Ich mein, wenn Anwendungsentwicklung für dich schon in, ja sag mal so, wenn du das schon in Erwägung ziehst,
kannst du ja programmieren, dich ganz scheiße finden.
Die beiden Ausbildungen nähern sich eh immer weiter an und es gibt heute eigentlich nicht mehr, also gibt's schon noch,
aber eigentlich ist es so, dass du als Admin auch eine Ahnung von der Software haben musst
und als Anwendungsentwickler von der Technikseite.
Also ich finde, man kann das eh nicht mehr so gut trennen.
Ich würde mir an deiner Stelle einfach für beide Sachen Plätze raussuchen und mich da bewerben
und den nehmen, womit der Laden am besten gefällt.
Es kommt irgendein doofes Minispiel.
Okay, doofes Minispiel.
Oh, hust so aus.
Oh, WTF.
Alp verrecken, ich seh nix.
Was mir irgendwie auch wieder Sinn dieses Modus aussieht.
Äh, was mach ich denn da? Moment.
Warte mal.
Wie hat der Kran noch mal funktioniert?
Als komischen Magnete, wie ging das noch mal?
Ach, das ist meistens, das ist eh total easy, das Zeug hier.
Ich seh nix.
Kann das sein, dass es irgendwie keine Hintergrundmusik gibt?
Das ist overrated, brauch man net.
Jebaited, overrated Hintergrundmusik.
Was? Ich finde den Link von deinem Schreibtischstuhl nicht mehr.
Könntest du noch mal posten? Es gibt es irgendeinen, das weiß der Sebaro bestimmt,
es gibt irgendeinen Bot-Kommando für den Stuhl.
Es gibt irgendeinen Bot-Kommando für den Stuhl.
Der Sebaro macht das, der weiß wie das funktioniert.
Ich weiß das Kommando auch nicht für den...
Doch, es gibt... Hä, gibt's nicht?
Gibt's kein Kommando für den Stuhl?
Also das Ding heißt Sedus Mr. 24 Leitwartenstuhl.
Sedus Mr. 24 Leitwartenstuhl.
Krasser Name, ne?
Kannste ja mal suchen danach. Ich zeig ihn gleich mal.
Wir machen jetzt gleich mal ne Chatling.
Ich zeig den Stuhl gleich mal im Browser hier.
Nach der Runde.
Ich seh nix. Das ist ein dummes Minigame? Ja.
Räudiges Minigame.
Wir gucken uns das gleich zusammen im Browser an.
Wenn wir die Runde hier fertig haben.
Ich bräuchte noch mal irgendwie nen Platt, dass ich Kram in die Mitte setzen kann.
Hintergruppenmusik gibt's nicht, oder? Gibt keine Hintergruppenmusik.
Hä?
Gibt's die Runde nicht. Haben wir keinen Bock drauf.
Doch, Toolos Soldiers, drei Wochen...
Ich denke schon, dass man in drei Wochen saumäßig viel machen kann.
Zumal du auch ja die Prüfung schon ein paar Mal gemacht hast
und weißt, was ungefähr auf dich zukommt.
Man muss halt sagen,
dass du jetzt halt nicht in drei Wochen irgendwie
die kompletten Jahre matte,
die kompletten Jahre Mathe lernen kannst.
Aber wenn es nur ein paar Gebiete gibt bei dir,
wo es halt nicht so gut läuft und woran das scheitert, das Ganze,
dann kann man in drei Wochen saumäßig viel machen.
Da gibt's bestimmt, muss ich aber sagen, hab ich keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Vorne hab ich den nicht in Anspruch genommen.
Jetzt bestimmt auch welche, die einem da helfen können,
sich vorzubereiten auf die Prüfung.
Das würde ein bisschen Geld kosten.
Oder man kennt halt welche.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass da vielleicht sogar
Profiservice besser ist.
Ich war das nicht genau.
Oh, fuck. Ausgerechnet in der...
Das ist jetzt nicht jener als ausgerechnet da,
wo ich keinen Kaktus gebaut hab, ne?
Ausgerechnet wo ich keinen Kaktus gebaut hab,
fuck.
Dummes Viech, er.
Ich bau da jetzt einen Kaktus hinten hin.
Oh, jetzt können wir einen verlieren.
Easy clap, easy win.
Also wie gesagt, ich glaub schon, dass man sich gut vorbereiten kann
in den Wochen.
Ist halt die Frage, wie viel hier fehlt.
Jetzt hab ich aber wirklich mehr, mehr Zeug, als ich irgendwie
auch ne Ansatzweise pflanzen könnte.
So.
Ich pflanz jetzt einfach mal hier ein bisschen random
große Zeug kommen.
Nicht, dass es jetzt groß was bringen würde.
Gleich danach gucken wir den Stuhl.
Und dann, wenn wir den Stuhl an uns angeguckt haben,
machen wir den Link im Chat.
Dass wir für zukünftige Fragen das gleich haben.
Also einen Bot.
Bot-Commando.
So, jetzt müssen wir jetzt gewonnen haben.
Ja, jetzt kommt die Dachlevel.
Was hab ich jetzt überlesen?
Und Internet of Things zu tun haben.
Ja gut, die müssen ja auch mit der Zeit gehen.
Ich find auch die Unterscheidung zwischen
Fachinformatiker, Systemintegration und
Anwendungsentwicklung ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so zeitgemäß.
Die meisten Leute, wenn man mal guckt,
es suchen sau viele Leute halt, die sich mit
beidem auskennen.
Vor ein paar Jahren war es voll im Trend, dass man
so ein Browser einblendet.
DevOps war damals so voll angesagt vom Namen her.
Heute schimpft sich das Ganze
Full-Stack-Developer.
Ich darf mein Chrome nicht anzeigen.
Warum darf ich mein Chrome nicht anzeigen?
Na gut, machen wir Window-Capture.
Desktop-Capture.
Display-Capture.
Also,
für denjenigen, der vorhin gefragt hat,
mein Stuhl, das Ding nennt sich
Seh-Los-Mister-24-Leit-Warten-Stuhl.
Sieht so aus.
Das sieht jetzt natürlich nicht so
spektakulär aus, das Ding.
Das sieht bei weitem nicht so stylisch aus wie vielleicht ein DX Racer.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde DX Racer mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr
stylisch. Das ist so eine Optik, da hat man sich Transat gesehen.
Da ist so die klassische Optik, finde ich, viel besser.
Und wir können jetzt mal
die Sachen nehmen. Es gab doch irgendwie so einen
Konfigurator bei denen auf der Seite.
So, und ich habe nämlich
die Kombination
mit Nackenstütze und
kann man das größer machen?
Mit Nackenstütze und in, ich glaube,
irgendwie so in grau.
Ne.
Grau. So, ja.
So, das ist meiner. Genau so sieht er aus.
Also auch die gleichen Armlehnen plus die
gleiche Rollen, gleiche Armlehnen plus unten silberne
Silberner Fuß anstatt schwarzer Fuß.
Und das Ding ist wirklich übertrieben geil.
Das Ding ist wirklich top. Kann man nichts sagen.
Können wir mal gucken, ob es vielleicht noch ein paar Bilder von dem Ding gibt,
wo man ein bisschen mehr draus sieht. Der hat nämlich ein paar richtig coole Sachen.
Gibt es Bilder mal
in groß oder so?
Ja, in groß. Genau.
Das ist genau die Konfiguration, die ich habe mit diesem Ding.
Du kannst hier neben die Armlehnen
hochfahren, runterfahren, nach vorne und nach hinten
und hier mit dem Schalter neben nach links und rechts.
Das ist sehr praktisch. Du kannst dir auch,
wenn du das richtige Modell hast, den Abstand zwischen Sitzplatz
und Rückenlehne einstellen. Und das Ding hier unten
federt auch ziemlich gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das hier hört.
Da hat mit meinem Gewicht auch keine Probleme.
Und auch hier nicht beim...
Ich stehe hier gerade auf.
Ich drücke mich jetzt nur mit den Armen gerade vom Stuhl hoch.
So habe ich kein Ding. Da wackelt nichts und gibt nichts nach.
Im Vergleich zum DXRacer ist das wunderbar.
Ich würde es eigentlich keinem empfehlen, sich zu kaufen.
Auch wenn das der beste Bürostuhl ist, den ich je hatte,
weil... Also wirklich gesagt, empfehlen kann ich den halt nicht.
Weil...
Weil... Weil...
Mehr muss ich dazu, glaube ich, nicht sagen.
Nutzt du gerade das Mod-Mic? Nein, ich nutze nicht das Mod-Mic.
Ich benutze das vom MMX300 gerade.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie viel ich für das Ding genau bezahlt habe.
Das war im, nennen wir es mal, Angebot.
Ja.
ProTech oder wie hieß der Pro?
Wie hieß denn der Shop,
wo ich das gekauft habe?
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Aber...
Der war da im Prinzip auch nicht wirklich viel billiger.
So. Und deswegen würde ich es keinem empfehlen,
sich zu kaufen.
ProTremo AG. Ja, genau.
Der Sebaro kennt sich aus.
Woher weiß der Sebaro, wo ich meinen Stuhl gekauft habe?
ProTremo AG, genau.
Ne, wir haben ProTremo...
AG.
Ja, genau, bei dem habe ich den Stuhl gekauft.
Guck mal, was der da jetzt kostet.
Haben die gar nicht mehr.
Ha.
Ups.
Den haben die gar nicht mehr.
Na gut, Pech gehabt.
Aber das ist halt wirklich krass teuer, das Teil.
Hast du das dann gerade an ein Interface angeschlossen,
weil die Qualität besser ist, als ich sonst gehört habe?
Also eigentlich müsste ich mich genauso anhören wie immer.
Ich habe nichts umgestellt.
Ich habe hier das MMX300 schon ewig über mein Audio-Interface laufen.
Und...
Ich wollte übrigens noch, in OBS fällt mir gerade ein,
ich wollte noch einen Noise Gate und einen, wie nennt sich das,
Low Cut, High Cut Filter machen,
wo man so die unteren Frequenzen rausschneidet.
Probieren wir jetzt gerade mal aus.
Moment, das mache ich jetzt mal kurz.
Jetzt habe ich die Leute, die zugucken, da kann ich das jetzt gerade mal machen.
Könnt ihr mir sagen, wie das klingt?
Falls es überhaupt OBS kann.
Noise Gate Gate Gain Compressor.
Ok, das kann, kann OBS anscheinend gar nicht.
Low Cut Filter, das kann, das kann OBS anscheinend gar nicht.
Zumindest sehe ich hier keinen zur Auswahl.
Noise Gate ist schön und gut, das könnte ich auch mal einrichten.
Da müsste ich jetzt aber ein bisschen rumspielen.
Also sprich quasi Voice Activation, dass das Mikrofon nicht immer an ist.
Allerdings, wie ich in OBS jetzt einen Low Cut mache, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Geht anscheinend nicht.
Ah, High Pass ist das gleich wie Low Cut, der ist logisch, klingt logisch.
Jetzt hier, wo du es sagst, ja, das stimmt schon.
Ne, da muss ich mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Hat anscheinend, OBS hat anscheinend nicht eingebaut.
Ne, ne, OBS hat sowas nicht eingebaut standardmäßig.
Also OBS hat standardmäßig plus eingebaut ein Kompressor, Gain, Noise Gate und irgendwie Noise Gate Suppression, was auch immer das sein soll.
Allerdings kann man VST Plugins wohl laden, ich weiß aber nicht, was es ist.
Audio Workstation oder irgendwie sowas.
Da gibt es dann bestimmt auch einen ordentlichen Filter.
Muss ich mal gucken, aber da werden wir jetzt heute mit leben können.
Ich könnte das Ding, ich könnte das natürlich auch über mein Audio Interface einstellen.
Da habe ich jetzt aber die Software nicht dazu installiert, weil das kann das auch alles.
Da habe ich einen Moto Track 16, falls das jemand wissen will.
Ja, Siebau, also falls du das findest über Amazon, den Stuhl, dann machen wir RefLink.
Ich habe den Biodynamic DT-770 mit Modmic 5, lohnt sich das MMX ja nicht, ist ja fast das gleiche oder ja, ist fast das gleiche.
Also das MMX ist quasi ein DT-770.
Mit ich glaube ein bisschen weniger Eingangswiderstand als der DT-770 in der Standard Ausführung, aber im Prinzip ist es wurscht.
Das ist das gleiche.
Der Sebaro hat sogar schon mal ein RefLink generiert für mich.
Ja, perfekt, setz den mal als Bot-Kommando rein.
So, weiter geht's, jetzt kommt das Dach, wir sind ja fast durch das Game durch.
Release du bald dein Face, ja bei einer Million Abos.
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas überlesen?
Der Stream Park drum ist kein Subbutton, ja, wie gesagt, ich habe mich der immer noch drum gekümmert.
Wann gibt es dann wieder IT-Mythen?
Ich habe ja schon mal was aufgenommen, das hat mir aber nicht so gefallen.
Ich sammle gerade noch ein paar Sachen, aber das gibt es demnächst wieder.
Schaust du das CSGO-Mager?
Was läuft denn gerade?
Stream Hack?
Stream Hack ist es, oder?
Ist es nicht wieder Stream Hack?
Habe ich so im Hinterkopf, dass es jetzt so langsam, aber sicher mal sein müsste.
Drehen hack.
Okay.
Kommt das Subbutton in den nächsten 30 Tagen, dann hebe ich meinen Prime-Sub auf?
Ne, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mich noch überhaupt null drum gekümmert bis jetzt.
Also glaube ich auch nicht, dass es demnächst kommen wird.
Mehr brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht hier.
Nehmen wir mal noch ein paar Triple-Nators.
Eigentlich brauche ich das alles nicht.
Moin Woodpecker.
Das hat eines der besten Hintergrund-Sounds irgendwie.
Das ist nicht nervig, es ist irgendwie angenehm anzuhören,
aber man kann es trotzdem laufen lassen die ganze Zeit.
Oh Donation.
Krasser Shit.
Muss ich jetzt nachgucken, weil mein Steamlabs abgekackt ist.
Muss ich gerade mal aufmachen.
Ist hier Ultra-Multitasking angesagt.
Jetzt habe ich schon wieder das Pflanzen von dieser komischen Kanone verkackt.
Ne, ne, sorry, nicht Donation, der hat gefollowed.
Bam, jawoll, hat funktioniert.
Connect with Twitch, jawoll.
Donations.
Das ist aber auch nochmal Donated.
Hast du dir schon mal D-Tube angeschaut?
Ja, habe ich gerade heute Mittag lustigerweise.
Ich habe es aber noch nicht so genau gecheckt, wie das funktioniert.
Nur so an Rande ehrlich gesagt.
Also so wie ich das verstanden habe, ist D-Tube so eine Mischung aus
Kryptowährung und Videoplattform.
Und anscheinend ist je nachdem, wie aktiv man auf der Plattform ist,
umso stärker wird das Gewichtet, was man macht.
Irgendwie so, ich habe es noch nicht, ich habe es nicht so genau gecheckt,
als ich mir das heute Mittag durchgelesen habe.
Ist aber lustig, dass du das sagst, weil ich habe gerade, wie gesagt,
heute Mittag mal geguckt.
Was mache ich denn da?
Hat jemand von euch Erfahrungen mit D-Tube?
Was, der Friseur hat die 360 rausgeholt?
Ernsthaft?
Moment, da muss ich jetzt mal mit dem Stream gucken.
Was hat er die 360 rausgeholt?
Hat er gar nicht erzählt, doch kein Mist, das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
Ich sehe ihn hier nicht mit 360.
Ach, er hat sie gezeigt, okay.
Ich habe die hier auch noch stehen.
Die steht auf der Xbox, über der Xbox One steht die sogar.
Oder? Ja.
Steht hier alles nebendran, über der Xbox One.
Also Microsoft gibt sich Mühe mit der Xbox One,
aber die haben den Start so krass verkackt, das ist nicht normal.
Ich frage mich immer noch, wie man das so verkacken konnte mit der Xbox One,
nach der wirklich besten Konsol der Generation davor.
Man weiß nicht, das wird nur Microsoft, das versteht man nicht.
Piss dich.
Ach, das Ding kann er nicht hochschießen.
Ja, stimmt, das war ja auf dem Dach so.
Ganz vergessen.
Lull.
Alter, Lull.
Bam.
Ja, stimmt, da gibt es ja die Blumentöpfe fürs Dach, das man bauen kann.
Ja, genau, Likes zählen unter anderem zur Generierung von Steam in Dollar.
Ach, stimmt, genau, so hieß der Kram,
welche man sich alle sieben Tage in Echtgeld auszahlen lassen kann,
wobei ein Teil davon in seine Steam-Power umgewandelt wird.
Semper Video hatte da ein kleines Wochenfazit gemacht,
wo das Prinzip noch mal beschrieben wurde.
Okay.
Lustig, dass du, wie gesagt, lustig, dass du sagst,
ich habe es mir erst am Mittag eingeschaut.
Ja, Z Pro, High Level.
Ich mache jetzt den, was wollen wir haben, 10.000, was gibt es denn?
Sonnenblumenupgrade.
Dachreiniger.
Dachreiniger, wir holen uns Dachreiniger.
Dachreiniger ist gut.
Dachreiniger brauchen wir, falls mal doch irgendwas durchkommt.
Sonnenblumenupgrade würde ich mir normalerweise holen,
allerdings bringt es das hier nicht,
weil die Level zu kurz sind in der Kampagne,
als dass man was von hat.
Und das andere können wir uns alles nicht leisten.
Bringt uns alles nichts.
Du gehst noch mal voll zu kurz zurück
oder hatte ich Activision wegen deiner Hassrede per mal gebannt?
Welche Hassrede meinst du, Tech Wolf?
Welche der Videos meinst du?
Ich habe doch in letzter Zeit gar nicht irgendwie großartig was zu kurz gemacht,
wo ich drüber hergezogen habe.
Oder? Hab ich? Nee, hab ich nicht.
Kann sein, dass ich schon gar nicht mehr weiß.
Das brauchen wir noch, das brauchen wir noch
und im Prinzip, wir nehmen das noch mit.
Es gibt doch dann auch noch diese Maiskanonen später,
die so Butter drüber werfen, das Ding brauche ich.
Eigentlich ist es vollkommen egal, was ich jetzt noch nehme.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Die vor drei Jahren mit dem Thema Boosting.
Meinst du dieses Video?
Falls du das meinst, gibt es da sogar noch ganz lustige Geschichten zu.
Meinst du das Video, wo ich irgendwas erzählt habe,
wie Activision einen neuen Tiefpunkt erreicht?
Meinst du das?
Das ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Oder meinst du das Reverse-Boosting-Video?
Ich habe mich so oft über Kot aufgeregt, da weiß ich hier das einzelne Video.
Hau da mal aus dem Kopf.
Vielen Dank für das rausholen von dem Stuhl,
es liegt leider nur etwas über mein Budget.
Ja, deswegen, wie gesagt, ich empfehle es ja auch keiner,
ich kann es keiner empfehlen, sich das Ding zu kaufen.
Preis-Leistung ist natürlich nicht gut.
Aber der Stuhl ist wirklich super.
Ansonsten hole ich Ikea Markus.
Ikea Markus geht immer.
Wenn sonst nichts geht, geht Ikea Markus.
Haben auch viele aus dem Stream hier Ikea Markus.
Und ich dachte, hat nicht sogar der Fabian auch Ikea Markus?
Ja, also zu diesem Activision hat er einen neuen Tiefpunkt-Video,
da gibt es sogar noch eine ganz lustige Geschichte.
Da hat mich damals der damalige Community-Manager angerufen.
Und damals wurde noch telefoniert, nicht dass man das irgendwie aufzeichnen konnte.
Und klar, ich glaube, da hatten sie alle ein bisschen Panik und so damals.
War halt gemein, ob ich das Video nicht löschen könnte.
Weil ansonsten wäre es halt nicht möglich, mich zu irgendwelchen Events und so einzuladen.
Ähm, warte mal.
Ist glaube ich nicht so taktisch geschickt, was ich hier gebaut habe.
Aber ich glaube, das kam nicht von ihm, diese Ansage.
Sondern eher von seinem Chef, dem das Video halt auch nicht gefallen hat.
Ich meine, ich kann das verstehen, dass ihm das Video nicht gefällt, ja.
Aber da sind sie selber dran schuld.
Ich kann ja nichts für, wenn sie so komische Dinge machen.
Oh nein, keine Ahnung zur Vorstellung des neuen Cods.
Na, es ging ja auch um generelle Events und Sachen, die da noch vielleicht kommen.
Und nicht nur Vorstellung des neuen Cods, alle möglichen Sachen.
Aber das hat sich ja dann eh erledigt, als die ja dann in Europa ein bisschen machen konnten, was sie wollten.
Dann wurden wir trotzdem eingeladen.
So, eigentlich können wir den mal verlieren, oder? Sehe ich das richtig?
Ich habe mich aber so übelst geschreckt, die Zombies.
Als erstes, wenn ich wieder 10.000 Gold habe, kaufe ich mir diese Maisraketen.
Da gibt es so einen doppelten Slot und dann kannst du dann hier Keten abfeuern von hinten, wo du hinklickst.
OP ist der Pflanze im ganzen Game.
Maxi ist beste Community-Managerin. Was? Maxi ist jetzt Community-Managerin?
Du meinst die Ganstar bzw. die High-Five-Maxi oder welche?
Ach stimmt, die ist ja jetzt bei Microsoft. Oder? Microsoft?
Ich hoffe bei Microsoft. Stimmt. Ja ne, da habe ich überhaupt nichts. Stimmt.
Max, wie sieht es mit einer Lebensabschnittsgefährtin aus?
Oh ne, das Thema brauche ich heute noch mal. Das hatten wir erst in einem der letzten Streams.
Das reicht. Das brauche ich nicht in jedem Stream.
Nicht, dass ich aus Versehen wieder einer als Playerin folge auf Twitter oder so.
Das Level ist immer sehr anspruchsvoll.
So, wir beschleunigen das Ganze jetzt mal.
Debated.
Oh.
Absolutes OP-Setup. Können nichts machen.
Ja, Z Pro, wer weiß, wer weiß. Ich meine in der heutigen Zeit ist sowas ja überhaupt kein Ding mehr.
In der heutigen Zeit ist das alles erlaubt.
Was ich auch geil fand, es haben sich auf Twitter wieder irgendwelche Leute darüber aufgeregt,
dass es ja nicht sein kann, dass in der Overwatch League irgendwie 10 Männer eine Frau und,
wie haben sie es geschrieben, eine Frau, 10 weiße Männer und einen Pok kasten würden.
Das ist nicht diverse genug. Das geht doch gar nicht. Da musste ich erst mal nachgucken, was zum Teufel ist ein Pok.
Bis ich dann rausgefunden habe, Pok ist die Abkürzung für People of Color.
Und dann haben sie sich darüber aufgeregt, dass es nicht geht, dass es nicht diverse genug ist, das Casting-Team von der Overwatch League.
Ich habe auch gedacht, ey, man kann sich echt über wirklich jeden Scheiß offenden, ey.
Aber dass sie einfach die besten Leute genommen haben, die sie finden konnten, dafür, das kommt keinem in den Sinn irgendwie.
Gibt es bei 30 Zombie-Kills eine Moab?
Da gibt es eine, wie hieß das Ding? Camp Str- ne, wie hieß das?
Fuck, wie hieß das Ding in Ghosts? Ist das nicht Camp Strike oder so?
Oh, wir haben Kletterzombies am Start. Also wir brauchen Sonnenblumen, Blumenfasel, das Ding.
Wie hieß das Ding denn? Ghosts, Ghosts Moab, das hieß nicht Moab, wie hieß das denn?
Camp Strike, sag doch Camp Strike. Kinetic Energy Missile Strike. 25 Kills.
Das da, das da, brava. Das da, das da, das da. Easy Win. Auf geht's.
Was demnächst? Speedrun zu Plants vs. Zombies?
Ne, ganz bestimmt nicht. Aber würde ich gern mal gucken. Den würde ich mir echt angucken.
Habt ihr GameStone Quick geguckt? Letzte Woche? Oh, wir gerade beim Thema Speedrun sind.
Bam.
Ich glaub wir bauen das nächste Mal am besten diese anderen Dinger, die slowen nämlich besser.
Ja, also die EU-Zeiten waren schlimm, das stimmt. Aber das war das erste von den größeren Speedrun Events, wo ich kaum was geguckt hab.
Das war nicht so geschickt, was ich hier gebaut hab. Aber vielleicht kriegen wir das, doch das Ding müsste eigentlich verrecken.
Und ich hab's eigentlich nur nicht geschaut, also hatte mehrere Gründe, aber was mir ein bisschen auf den Sack ging, ist jetzt halt mein Problem.
Kann ich jetzt nicht allgemein sagen, dass es schlecht wäre oder so, aber es ist halt das, was mir nicht gefallen hat.
Komm, kannst ab. Jawoll, nice.
Ich glaub ich muss hier ne Bombe verwenden. Ich war zu langsam.
Scheiß Build Order hier.
Ja, das hat mir dieses Jahr nicht so gut gefallen, dass der Chat Chat Sub-Only war. Das ist wie gesagt zwar mein Problem und meine Sache, dass mir das nicht gefallen hat.
Letztendlich hat ihn der Erfolg wieder recht gegeben, er hat wieder sau viel gesammelt. Aber ich mag das nicht, wenn irgendjemand auf Twitch mit so Sachen wie Sub-Only-Chat oder auch Sub-Only-Words und sowas.
Das finde ich, das hat immer so den, weiß nicht, ich komme da immer so vor, als soll ich dazu gezwungen werden, irgendwie den Sub abzuschließen. Und ich will lieber freiwillig subben.
Also selbst wenn ich normalerweise gesubbt hätte, sub ich dann nicht. Obwohl ich normal gesubbt hätte, wisst ihr wie ich mein. Also ich hätte normalerweise wahrscheinlich gesubbt, also auch bei anderen Channels.
Aber ich sub dann nicht, weil ich immer das Gefühl habe sie wollen, dass ich subbe, um mich dazu zu zwingen. Obwohl ich eh gesubbt hätte. Also jetzt schwierig zu erklären, wie ich das meine, aber das hat mich halt genervt.
So Butter, auf Butter, Zombies Butter, jawoll, gut.
Ich mach nie Sub-Only-Chat, warum soll ich Sub-Only-Chat machen? Sub-Only-Chat ist total bescheuert.
Selbst wenn man einen großen Channel hat, wo viel los ist, warum sollte man Sub-Only-Chat machen?
Und ich gucke öfters mal wirklich große Channels mit 3.000, 4.000, 5.000 Zuschauern. Klar, da ist schon teilweise übelst krasses gesperrmert. Es kommt auch ein bisschen immer so auf die Persönlichkeit vom Streamer jetzt an, was da genau abgeht im Chat.
Aber für mich ist es bei Twitch einfach so, dass 50% ist der Livestream, also wenn man es mal grundsätzlich so in zwei Sachen einteilen müsste, 50% ist der Livestream und 50% ist für mich der Chat.
Für mich, wie gesagt, kann ja variieren, je nachdem. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die sagen Chat ist das nervigste an Twitch, aber ich finde der Chat ist das, was Twitch im Vergleich zu anderen Streaming-Plattformen ausmacht.
Das ist der Grund, eines der Gründe, warum mir YouTube-Streaming nicht gefällt. Der Chat ist einfach Mist. Außerdem fehlen mir diese ganze Twitch-Rumge-Meme da.
Das hat mir dieses Jahr nicht gefallen. Ich habe trotzdem ein bisschen geguckt auf dem Handy und so, aber ich habe relativ wenig geguckt.
Das hat mich so genervt am Anfang, dass das Sub-Ondi war, dass ich überhaupt keinen Bock mehr hatte dann.
Und sie haben es, finde ich, mit der Moderation im Chat auch ganz schön übertrieben.
Also ich meine, oh jetzt muss ich mal kurz aufpassen. Kann man die Leiter irgendwie wegmachen? Kann die Leiter löschen, okay.
Ich finde es ja okay, wenn man den Chat insofern moderiert, dass man Sachen, die ganz klar zum Beleidigen vom Streamer oder zu demjenigen, der gerade seinen Speedrun vor der Kamera sitzt,
wenn da Sachen im Chat kommen, die ganz klar darauf abzielen, diesen Typ irgendwie fertig zu machen, zu beleidigen. Das kann man ja löschen, da sagt ja keiner was dagegen.
Aber man muss doch nicht alles löschen. Ich meine, ich wurde letztes Jahr irgendwie gebannt, weil ich Krill geschrieben habe.
Und ich meine, das ist eine Sache, die habe ich sogar aus einem dieser Speedrun-Streams. Und man muss doch da echt nicht pipslicher sein als der Papst und für alles irgendwie die Leute bannen.
Und ansonsten muss man halt auch mal sagen, dass auf diesen Speedrun-Events sind halt viele, wo nicht unbedingt auf den ersten Blick ersichtlich ist, ob sie sich jetzt selbst als Mann oder Frau sehen.
Drücken wir das mal so aus. Was ja auch überhaupt nicht schlimm ist, obwohl ich auch absolut nichts dagegen habe. Ihr wisst, ich bin der Ansicht, es soll wirklich jeder machen, was er will.
Aber wenn halt jemand da sitzt, der relativ männlich aussieht und eine tiefe Stimme hat und dann schreibt jemand im Chat, keine Ahnung, blablabla, was macht er da?
Und wird dann gebannt, weil er das Wort eher verwendet hat, obwohl er es einfach nicht besser wissen konnte. Das sind auch so Sachen, wo ich sage, man muss es halt echt nicht übertreiben mit der Moderierung des Chats.
Ansonsten finde ich es ja gut, dass das ein Event ist, wo es halt da in dieser Richtung freizügig zugeht und keiner eigentlich großartig rumhatet. Das ist eine super Geschichte.
Aber man kann ja nicht von jedem im Chat warten, dass er das sofort richtig einordnet.
So, das da, Brauer.
Das da, das da, das da, ähm. Max, was sagst du zu Escape vom Tarkov, noch nie gespielt.
Im Prinzip wird er genau das gleiche hier an Zombies am Start. Nehmen wir das noch mit und das noch und das müsste eigentlich reichen.
Ne, Miros meint, ich mein gar nicht einen speziellen Run. Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht mal, ich hab das an keinen speziellen irgendwie gedacht.
Das war nur, finde ich, manchmal total übertrieben. Genauso, ich weiß nicht, ob das, ich glaube, das war letztes Jahr.
Da hat jemand Wind Waker Speed Run und hat halt erklärt die und die Glitches, die er verwendet. Und die haben halt alle immer irgendeinen Namen, diese Fehler und diese Bugs, die da ausgenutzt werden.
Oftmals halt nach dem Erfinder, beziehungsweise der, der es rausgefunden hat. Und da hat er halt im Wind Waker Speed Run gesagt, irgendwie Cosmo Hop.
Und da sind die ganzen, mein Cosmo nennt sich ja nicht mal Cosmo, und da sind sie auf die Barrikaden gegangen alle, weil er ja jetzt irgendwie Dead Naming oder wie das heißt betreibt.
Also quasi, also Leute ey, man muss es doch nicht übertreiben. Man hat einfach die Sache technisch so benannt, wie sie halt genannt wird.
Da haben sie sich alle aufgeregt, ey. Und das finde ich, man muss es, da muss man es einfach nicht übertreiben.
Was ist dein Lieblingsspiel aus dem Jahr 2017? Ich würde sagen, Divinity Originals in 2.
Oh, ich hab Übelscheiße geplantet. Bam, so, perfekt.
Die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Ja, Laupetien denke ich auch. Sehe ich ähnlich.
Also man hat, man verdient, also es ist selten bisher geglückt, dass man quasi damit, dass man Sachen gelöscht hat oder verboten hat, die Leute zum Umdenken bewegt hat.
Sondern eher jetzt erst recht.
Ich baue ja gerade übrigens übelsten Crap.
Funky, das finde ich lustig, weil erinnert sich noch jemand an das Video, was ich gemacht habe, wo ich erzählt habe, wo ich zum ersten Mal mich verliebt habe im Urlaub in Anna, weiß das noch jemand?
Und das hat sie mir auch versucht beizubringen, auszusprechen. Aber ich kann das bis heute nicht.
Nee, das war, das war die, die kam, die kam aus München. Das ist doch was Bayerisches.
Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt?
Moment, was mache ich denn hier? Das da, das da.
So, ich muss jetzt mal hier ein bisschen, ein bisschen aufpassen, das muss da hin.
Das müssen wir hier ausbauen.
Konzentraten, übelsten Crap gebaut. Guck mal, ich hab hier kaum ausgebaut, 1000 Dinger, Überschuss schon.
Und die Cooldowns auch nicht richtig benutzen und sowas.
Ich gekreue die geschlecht, alter Alarm.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal schnell zwei Plumptöpfe da vorne hinsetzen und Block in den Wall bauen.
Ja, das halten wir, das passt. Easy Hold.
Können nix.
Hier kann noch Mais hin und hier kann auch, im Prinzip kann überall noch Mais hin.
Darf man Songrequest tätigen? Ich hab grad keine Hintergrundmusik laufen, aber kannste mal machen, ja.
Wenn noch was Gutes dabei ist, mach ich es an.
Guck mir aber vorher an, was das ist.
Weil wir hatten auch schon Songrequests, die waren jetzt nicht so toll.
Jetzt ab jetzt ist Easy Hold, jetzt kann halt schon mal passieren.
Junge, was ein Game. Und beste.
Oh, ich bin voll kaputt. Obwohl ich heute den ganzen Tag nichts gemacht habe.
Also am besten, wenn man kaputt ist, obwohl man nichts gemacht hat.
Da fragt mich immer, das geht eigentlich gar nicht. Aber es geht doch.
Unter dem letzten Video, was ich hochgeladen hab, für über Internetausbau in Deutschland, waren wieder total viele Leute verwirrt über die Bezeichnungen der Provider früher für ihre Anschlüsse.
Ich mein, das ist auch echt verwirrend, ne?
Diese Sache mit mal ist mit K Kilo Byte gemeint, mal ist mit K 1000 gemeint.
Es ist echt weird.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum sie es nicht schafft, mal einheitlich zu machen.
Hast du mal fortan ausprobiert?
Oh, was ist das denn?
Die Musik ist mir jetzt zu nervenaufreimend.
Was? Ich hab dich komplett verwirrt, warum?
Was hab ich gemacht?
Debated
Debated, overrated
Outdated
Das ist aber auch echt bescheuert.
Manche schreiben 100 K und meinen damit eigentlich 100.000 Kilo.
Allerdings dann für, wahrscheinlich je nachdem, Bit oder Byte.
Das weiß man nicht so genau.
Bit, aber man weiß es nicht, weil sie schreiben es ja nicht hin.
Das ist weird, das ist echt weird die Bezeichnungssache da.
Also ich kann jeden verstehen, der da nicht durchblickt.
Ich mein, man kann doch nicht 100 K schreiben und meint damit eigentlich 100.000 und dann wiederum Kilo.
Das ist, ah, mind blown.
Warum macht man es so kompliziert?
Man kann doch gleich Megabit hinschreiben, dann ist das viel einfacher.
Und bis zu, bis zu ist natürlich ganz wichtig.
Bis zu muss sein.
Telekom macht bei uns ja auch bis zu 200.000.
Oder bis zu 200 K.
Oder bis zu 200 M.
Bit, wie auch immer sie es jetzt bezeichnen.
Magst du aus welchen Serien kannst du empfehlen?
Ich hab nicht viele Serien geguckt in letzter Zeit.
Also keine wirklich.
Ja, ohne bis zu ist das kein deutscher Internet-Tarif.
Das ist auch schlimm.
Also wenn das bis zu sich in Grenzen hält, fände ich das ja okay.
Ja, dass man das als Anbieter vielleicht nicht auf das Bit genau vorhersagen kann.
Für was die Leitung jetzt taugt.
Okay, ja, versteh ich.
Vor allem halt über Kupfer.
Aber bis zu, quasi 100 verkaufen oder bis zu 16 verkaufen, wie das früher war.
Und dann kommen irgendwie, kommt DS Lite oder sowas an.
Das ist halt Verarschung.
Bis zu 16.000 und du kriegst dann 364.
Da denkt man auch, ja.
Denkt mich.
Debated.
Das ist richtig, das ist richtige Debate.
Bis zu Internet-Anschluss in Deutschland ist quasi so die Definition von Debated.
Eigentlich immer.
Ja, evil whatever sei froh, dass es bei D2M-Bit waren.
Es gibt auch Leute, die haben nur 364K gekriegt.
Also das K jetzt für Kilo-Bit.
Vor allem soll nix der Dritte.
Easy win.
Oh ne, fuck.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Gefahr abgewendet.
Das ist falsch, was ich hier gebaut hab.
Muss ich mal kurz ein bisschen aufpassen.
Aber der Kürbis, den muss ich behalten.
Falls hier irgendwas drüber hüpft.
CyberGear123, ja geht mir auch so.
Ich würde auch gern Overwatch spielen.
Aber ranked ist mir zu nervig, zu stressig.
Und nicht vom Spiel her stressig, sondern das Drumherum, das nervt mich.
Was hast du jetzt alles auf deinem Server laufen?
Oh, da muss ich mal in mich gehen, das hab ich schon alles laufen.
Spamfilter, also nicht Spamfilter, Addfilter.
P-Hole.
TV-Server mit zwei USB-DVBC-Karten.
Ich hab da so viel drauf laufen, aber ich administriert so selten, weil es einfach funktioniert, dass ich das gar nicht mehr weiß.
Ah ja, mein Router natürlich fürs Internet.
OnCloud.
Ich muss da jetzt mal drauf gucken.
Ich guck da jetzt mal drauf nebenbei.
Es funktioniert einfach alles, das ist das Problem, deswegen kann ich es gar nicht so genau sagen.
Es sind so 6, 7 Sachen.
Hoch.
Ja, ich kann mich von hier nicht drauf verbinden, weil ich mein SSH Key nicht hab.
Na dann, dann kann ich es dir nicht sagen.
Hab ich denn da sonst noch drauf?
Ich starte jetzt mal meine Linux VM oder Key drauf, also lock mich mal drauf ein, weil irgendwie hab ich grad Brainlag.
Mir fällt das gar nicht ein, was da alles drauf läuft.
Aber da sieht man mal, das Schöne ist, wenn man das einmal aufgesetzt hat ordentlich, dann geht's einfach.
Und die Sachen sind so voll normal für einen.
Also das waren jetzt so die vier Hauptsachen, aber ich hab da noch mehr drauf.
So, ich guck jetzt mal, was hab ich denn da eigentlich alles drauf?
Ich bin nämlich selbst irgendwie ein bisschen verwirrt, dass mir das nicht einfällt.
Oh, guck mal mal.
Also, was haben wir da alles drauf?
Ich guck jetzt grad mal hier auf den zweiten Bildschirm.
Ja, genau, genau. Also, ich hab drauf mein Internetzugang Router.
Eine VM, wo ich mit meiner 1080 TI mal bisschen Grafikkarten Pass-Through getestet hab.
Was wunderbar läuft, kann man sogar BDO drüber spielen dann.
Einen Sync für die Fritzbox, was On-Cloud-Kontakte und sowas angeht, genau.
Einen Fileserver natürlich, wo sie irgendwie meine 20 TB vollkriegen für Windows.
TV-Server, On-Cloud, Backup und Adblocker DNS. Ich glaub, das war's jetzt alles.
Mehr seh ich jetzt hier in der Historie grad nicht, wo ich was dran gemacht hab.
Mal gucken, List.
Was ist das hier nochmal?
Irgendeine Testkiste.
Genau, das waren die Sachen, die ich da drauf laufen hab.
Was hast du als Hypervisor laufen? Ich hab KVM und LXC für Container.
Ach, jetzt soll ich Minigames machen, jaja.
Das kann man nicht komplett machen, das hier ausbauen, weil das dauert Stunden.
Kein Hyper-V. Nee, das ist eine Linux-Server, da ist mit Hyper-V nichts.
Windows-Server, als hätt ich einen Windows-Server hier stehen.
Ich muss Windows schon auf dem Desktop benutzen, weil leider immer noch kein Weg dran vorbeifährt.
Äh, führt.
Findest du Plans, weil das Tomies nicht ein bisschen easy? Doch, aber gerade deswegen ist es geil.
Sonst könnt ich mich überhaupt nicht auf den Chat konzentrieren.
Ach, Windows ist gar nicht so schlecht. Windows ist auf dem Desktop nicht schlecht.
Vor allem Windows 10 mit dem letzten Update, muss ich sagen.
Ähm, auf dem Desktop find ich das wirklich mittlerweile benutzbar.
Es fehlen mir immer noch ein paar Sachen, die ich gerne hätte, bzw. die es jetzt unter anderem Betriebssystemen gibt.
Ein ordentliches Terminal, eine ordentliche Shell, aber das kann man sich ja alles nachrüsten, auch wenn es nicht so schön integriert ist dann.
Aber allein schon, weil die meisten Spiele nur unter Windows laufen, bleibt ja halt nichts anderes übrig.
Ah, sinnlose Minigames.
PowerShell ist ein guter Ansatz, ja das stimmt.
Aber ich mag trotzdem den Unix Shell Ansatz mit reinem Text lieber.
Find ich einfach simpler durchzusteigen und Sachen damit zu machen.
Aber PowerShell ist gut.
Allerdings, PowerShell ist eher sowas, ich finde PowerShell ist nichts zum täglich arbeiten, sondern eher zum Server automatisieren.
Dafür ist PowerShell gut.
So täglich damit arbeiten würde ich auch nicht wollen.
Fress auf, flop, schnippschnapp.
Das schlechteste Minigame, ja das ist echt dumm.
Das ist ja noch nicht mal sonderlich schwer oder so.
Ups, das hab ich nicht aufgepasst.
Perfekt, ganz toll.
Ups, fail.
Das ist richtig intensives Gameplay.
High Octane Gameplay ist hier angesagt.
Was sagst du zu Proxmox?
Für Leute, die es nicht selbst aufsetzen wollen, ist das eine gute Sache.
Ich mach das lieber selbst.
Da bist du halt auch vollkommen frei in dem, was du machst.
Ist das langweilig, das Minigame.
Das ist wirklich dumm.
Welche Elo ist das?
Also ich muss sagen, das ist schon ziemlich skill-lastig gerade.
Das ist kurz vor Top 500 würde ich sagen.
Aber es ist definitiv High Grandmaster.
Ich glaub, da sind wir uns alle einig, oder?
Also das ist nicht der Grandmaster, das ist High Grandmaster.
Rekt.
Hochkomplex.
Vielleicht muss ich halt mal was machen, ne?
Hatten zu, mal hier irgendwie Zeugs hinsetzen oder so.
So, zack, easy, debated.
Warten einfach, bis es aufgefressen ist.
Easy.
Da setzen wir hinten nochmal was hin, falls wir das jetzt wegfressen.
Machen wir die hintere Reihe nochmal.
Was soll das hier?
Schnapp.
Oh, das ist High Octane, ey.
Wahnsinn.
Ich brauch nochmal einen Blubentopf, jawoll.
Komplexes Gameplay.
So siehts aus.
TF.
Wie bist du eigentlich auf Blends vs. Zombies gekommen?
Ganz einfach, das haben wir Silvester angefangen.
Oder Weihnachten? War es Weihnachten oder Silvester? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Haben wir das angefangen zu spielen? Bis halt zum Poollevel? Jetzt spielen wir es fertig.
Ja, man sollte mal wirklich so Blends vs. Zombies Pro League oder sowas mal andenken.
Wobei ihr müsst euch mal auf YouTube ein paar Videos von diesen Endlosleveln angucken.
Da gibt es Leute, die haben irgendwie bis Flagge 5000 oder so gespielt.
Da kommen nur noch von diesen ultra fetten Zombies dann am Ende.
Was hältst du von Docker?
Aber ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt in der richtigen Reihenfolge alles hier gesehen habe.
Ach ja, Serious Max, das stimmt. Das ist wichtig, das muss ich euch jetzt mal kurz zeigen.
Habe ich hier eine ordentliche Shell? Moment, das muss ich euch zeigen. Das ist jetzt ganz, ganz, ganz essentiell.
Also das muss.
Ja, auf. Öffne dich.
Fuck, ich habe, ich habe keinen.
Habe ich, habe ich Windows? Habe ich Linux vor Windows installiert? Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Nein, habe ich nicht. Scheiße.
Nee, habe ich nicht installiert.
Kann ich euch jetzt gar nicht zeigen.
Das aber dumm.
Sonst hätte ich euch nämlich das hier zeigen müssen.
Fuck, ich kann Windows, meine Güte, ey.
Das ist wieder mal sowas, was unter Windows nicht ordentlich funktioniert, weil du keine gescheite Shell hast.
Ich wollte euch jetzt eigentlich das Beste zeigen, was.
Geht das jetzt?
Ja, ja, okay, es geht. Also Leute, passt mal auf.
Eine Sache ist ganz wichtig, wenn ihr, wenn ihr ein Terminal verwendet.
Ihr müsst ab und zu mal Parrot.live euch runterladen.
Weil nur das, das als ich war.
Ohne geht nicht.
Das muss oder am besten noch gepaart, dass wir irgendwie.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man hier was nachinstalliert. Was ist das überhaupt für eine Bash? Wo kommt die her?
Dazu weg. Aber das, das ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Ich muss gerade mal kurz was gucken, Leute.
Ah.
Okay.
Weiter geht's.
Ja, also es müsste ja, wenn ihr mal eine ordentliche Shell habt und es nicht diese Kacke hier, wie unter Windows.
Da muss unbedingt ein Curl Parrot.live rein.
Irgendjemand hat auch gerade gefragt, was ich zu Docker denke.
Ich persönlich bin, weiß nicht, nicht so der großartige, große Docker-Fan.
Das ist nicht wirklich schlecht oder so.
Ich hatte bis jetzt noch kein Anwendungsszenario, wo ich gesagt habe, jawoll, dafür wird Docker genau das Richtige.
Gibt's bestimmt, aber ich hat's bis jetzt noch nicht.
Und ich meine, Linux-Container ist ja nicht Docker, nicht synonyme Docker.
Für viele Leute ist Docker gleich Linux-Container, beziehungsweise Linux-Container gleich Docker, aber das stimmt ja nicht.
Docker ist ja nur das Frontend.
So was wie LXC, auch im Endeffekt, so Tools dafür sind.
Gibt's ja noch mehrere Sachen.
Docker läuft auch unter Windows ja mit Hyper-V unten drunter.
Was war denn Docker noch mal, das ein Anwendungscontainer Frontend?
Quasi ein, das ist ja mittlerweile viel mehr.
Das hat ja noch Cluster-Geschichten dabei und alles Mögliche.
So, zack, zack, wir machen unser Standard-Setup, da kann eigentlich nicht viel schiefgehen.
Was da noch? Easy Win?
Könntest du nicht einen neuen Slot kaufen?
Der hat 20.000 gekostet, können wir doch nicht kaufen.
Den Matschkürbis nicht, den brauchen wir nicht.
Too easy alles.
Bezüglich meiner Frage wegen Proxmox vorhin, kenne ich mich zwar mit Linux aus, aber noch nicht wirklich mit Virtualisierung.
Was genau meinst du mit selber machen, das ganze KVM-Management?
Ja, über Proxmox kannst du halt mal das machen, was übers Webinterface angeboten wird.
Klar, du kannst auch auf der Kommandozeile irgendwas machen.
Aber wenn ich mit Proxmox was über die Kommandozeile machen muss, ist die Frage, warum brauche ich das dann überhaupt?
Ich sehe da den Vorteil auch nicht von.
Ich meine, es ist nicht schwierig KVM über Kommandozeile zu verwalten.
Und wenn man sowas wie LXC haben will, beziehungsweise LXC2 für Container, das finde ich super einfach über Kommandozeile.
Ich brauche das Webinterface von...
Ups, siehst du, jetzt habe ich dann aufgepasst, Leute.
Jetzt muss ich hier schon die Bombe usen, weil ich dann aufgepasst habe.
Loop.
Okay, der stirbt da nicht von.
Jetzt einfach hier aufrüsten und gut ist.
Zu Container kann ich gleich was sagen.
Ich bin nur kaputt irgendwie, das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Ich habe nichts gemacht den ganzen Abend, trotzdem voll kaputt.
Auf, bam.
Nennt man Montag?
Naja, mit dem Unterschied, dass ich heute nicht mehr arbeiten war.
Dann könnte ich ja verstehen, dass ich kaputt bin.
Aber für mich war heute quasi dritter Wochenendertag.
Trotzdem kaputt.
Lul.
Und ich weiß nicht genau worum.
Ich gucke gleich entscheiden, wenn ich das hier aufgebaut habe.
Ich sehe, dass es ein paar Fragen noch gibt.
Mach Blatt.
Dann muss man hier noch alles aufrüsten, dann passt es.
Dann kann ich im Prinzip restlichen Runde AFK spielen.
Machst du noch ein Fünftelzeit-Youtuber oder warum dritter Wochenendertag?
Ja, genau.
Also ich arbeite nur vier Tage.
Kann man Programmieren zu Hause lernen?
Ja klar.
Klar geht das.
Die meisten haben Programmieren zu Hause gelernt.
Dann kann man das auch machen.
Was für eine Backendsprache würdest du empfehlen, ausgeschlossen Node.js und PHP?
Backend, du meinst für Web-Geschichten?
Ich würde mal sagen so etwas wie Ruby und Python, weil damit hat man auch was für andere Bereiche, wenn es nicht unbedingt Web ist.
Und halt, wenn man wirklich sagt, man will in dieser Web-Richtung weiterhin was machen, was was auch bringt.
Dann kann man sich ja auch mal C-Sharp angucken, bzw. auch wenn es mir schwer fällt es zu sagen Java.
Weil das einfach im Business-Umfeld stehen sie da irgendwie alle drauf.
Aber wenn ich auswählen müsste zwischen C-Sharp und Java, würde ich eindeutig immer C-Sharp nehmen.
Ich finde das einfach eine ganze Ecke irgendwie konsistenter, schöner und der Entwicklung läuft eher so in die Richtung, wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Java ist irgendwie sowas, da müsste mir schon einer wirklich viel Geld für bezahlen, dass ich da hauptsächlich Java programmieren würde.
Was hältst du persönlich von Python als Sprache in sich für die Zukunft?
Ja, das ist eine super Sprache und auch eine super Sprache für die Zukunft.
Damit macht man auf jeden Fall gar nichts verkehrt, wenn man Python lernt.
Und es ist gleichzeitig auch eine gute Sprache zum Einsteigen.
Viele interessante neue Sachen gibt es standardmäßig erst bei Python, weil es halt da drin ausprobiert wird.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
So jetzt haben wir es eigentlich, easy life.
Ups, hoffentlich. Macht ihr Blatt?
Wobei wisst ihr was?
Wir haben lange Fackeln hier.
Max, schaust du Overwatch League?
Sie schabt aber da mit Mono ein.
Warum mit Mono?
Wenn du unter Windows bist, stellt sich die Frage ja im Prinzip nicht.
Und wenn du unter Linux bist oder Mac, dann kannst du mittlerweile.NET Core verwenden.
Mono würdest du noch nehmen, wenn es irgendwelche GUI Sachen sein sollen.
Aber selbst da gibt es mittlerweile Ansätze, die mit.NET Core funktionieren.
Also Mono würde ich nichts Neues mit aufsetzen.
Welche Distribution hast du dann als Host, auf dem deine VMs laufen?
Arch Linux? Nee, Ubuntu Server.
Ubuntu Server, ich bin Ubuntu Fan, was Server angeht.
Ich meine, in den meisten Firmen ist es eher Red Hat.
Manchmal in Deutschland haben wir auch ein paar Suze.
Aber eigentlich sind es in Firmen eher entweder Red Hat oder irgendwie eines der Red Hat-Klone,
so wie CentOS oder halt Debian.
Aber ich mag Ubuntu Server.
Ubuntu Server vom Desktop bin ich kein großer Fan von.
Ubuntu Server gefällt mir.
Ich finde, es ist genau die richtige Mischung aus Aktualität der Pakete,
Supportlänge, wie man es bedient und wo die Dateien liegen.
Mir persönlich gefällt Ubuntu Server von den ganzen Linux-Distributionen am besten.
Was ist an Red Hat so besonders, dass es von Unternehmen benutzt wird?
Na gut, es ist eine große Firma dahinter und man kann sich Support kaufen.
Da stehen die Leute drauf.
Viele teure Profi-Enterprise-Business-Software ist für Red Hat zertifiziert.
Und tja, dann ist es halt Red Hat, was bei den Firmen läuft.
Moment, ich will gar nicht, ich will mal zum Laden.
Nee, der neunte Platz kostet 20k, haben wir noch nicht.
Das klingt übelst OP, das Ding.
Aber das kann man hier auf dem Dach nicht pflanzen.
Die Dachlevel sind total langweilig, da kann man nicht viel Variation machen.
Im Prinzip kann man da eigentlich nur immer den gleichen Shit bauen.
Das braucht man nicht, diese komischen Bungee-Zombies baut man einfach neu, gut ist.
Schön was vergessen, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich so im Arsch bin, ganz da nichts geschafft.
Ja, Sie bauen oder stehen Sie halt drauf in der Büsiness-Welt, finden Sie das geil.
Da muss ich zu allem, wenn es da keinen Support zu kaufen gibt, dann wollen Sie das nicht.
Zumal halt die meisten Support-Verträge, zumindest die Antworten, die von dort kommen,
auch oftmals total sinnlos sind, ja.
Die machen das Minimalste, was sie machen müssen, um ihren Support-Vertrag zu erfüllen.
Also oftmals bringt es hier gar nicht was.
Wer schon mal bei Oracle Support-Calls aufgemacht hat, weiß, was ich meine.
Das kannst du dir im Prinzip auch zu 99% gleich sparen.
Bei Dallas Fuel läuft es nicht so optimal, ja das stimmt.
Also das Sie verloren haben gegen Soul Dynasty, konnte ich verstehen.
Und es war knapp.
Ich meine, das ist mit das beste Team zur Zeit.
Zumindest nach der Einschätzung, die man so davor hatte.
Dass sie jetzt gegen LA so auf den Sack gekriegt haben, war halt unglücklich.
Aber man sollte jetzt nicht nach den ersten zwei Spielen irgendwie den Kopf in den Sand stecken,
beziehungsweise sagen, oh jetzt ist alles vorbei.
Es kann doch einfach mal an einem Tag scheiß laufen, am nächsten Tag haust du bitte alle.
Und die sind lange genug mit dabei, dass sie wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Soul ist echt gut.
Vor allem der eine Ana Main, meinst du Ryu Shi Hong oder wie der Typ heißt?
Oh fuck, koreanische Name, Ryu Shi Hong.
Wie heißt der Typ?
Kranse Name.
Levy.
Ja, den meinst du, ok.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man ihn genau ausspricht.
Am besten ist der eine Support Spieler von Lunatic High, also der, der jetzt nicht bei Soul Dynasty ist.
Der hat sich halt K.O.X. geschrieben und da hatten die Caster halt immer Schwierigkeiten.
Weil das hat ihn halt standardmäßig jeder erstmal K.O.X. ausgesprochen, was halt recht unglücklich gewesen ist.
Weil ich finde es ja gut, dass die Koreaner auch mal koreanische Namen haben.
So in Starcraft 2 hatte ich so das Gefühl, die Koreaner hatten einfach, suche dir ein englisches Wort aus einem Wörterbuch raus.
Also oftmals so Namen.
Wo man sich dann gefragt hat, was für K.O. das ist ein Koreaner? Innovation oder sowas.
Was halt überhaupt nicht Koreanisch geklogen hat.
Kann er das aufheben, das Ding? Ja, ist klar.
Kriegen sie den jetzt endlich mal kaputt?
Rekt.
Das ist ja schon, es liegt ja eine ganze Weile auseinander in dem Livestream, wo ich mich über Internetausbau in Deutschland ausgelassen habe. Das ist ja schon eineinhalb Monate her oder so. Ich habe gedacht, es wird mal wieder Zeit, sich da drüber auszulassen.
Ne, ne, hat mit dem Livestream nichts zu tun.
So.
Ja, das stimmt. Über Internetausbau in Deutschland kann man sich mal aufregen.
Eigentlich jeden Tag. Vor allem, wenn dann wieder der Regierungssprecher irgendwas postet, was garantiert nichts wird. Einfach da oben mal was gepostet zu haben.
Max, hast du mein Bild auf Twitter gesehen mit meiner Bandbreite?
Jetzt haben hier viele Leute ihre Bandbreite geschickt. Was war deins? Welches war dein Bild?
Was war deins? Was war dein Bild?
Was war deines Bildes? Was war deines Bildes?
und 150 millisekunden pingen, das ist da wirklich bitter
also das ist echt wenig
bin auch bei der telekom immer, 2h habe ich einen disconnect
was hast du für einen anschluss?
also beim normalen dsl ist es ja so, dass es einmal 24h im disconnect gibt
das kannst du aber in deiner fritzbox einstellen, falls du eine fritzbox hast
dass die den auch schon vorher macht
also ich hab es bei mir auch auf 3 oder 4 Uhr eingestellt
obwohl ich es mit vdsl eigentlich gar nicht bräuchte
einfach weil ich mir einbilde, dann...
keine Ahnung
klappt es besser, weiß nicht
bis denn das bei mir ab und zu mal das internet vdsl in synchronisierung verloren geht
dass die telekom nicht gebacken bekommt
was bevorzugst du, internetkabel oder dsl?
das ist mir scheißegal
das was die beste bandbreite hat, upload technisch
und das ist aktuell bei mir gerade vdsl 100, drunter 40, ab
wenn jetzt unity media, sagen wir mal, was ordentliches rausbringen würde
400, drunter 40, ab, würde ich mir sofort unity media nehmen
wenn die telekom dann irgendwann noch mehr hat, nehme ich das wieder
so ist es mir vollkommen egal, über was das kommt
es gibt immer noch keine melonen
oh, da kommen die fetten
muss man jetzt aufpassen
das da, das da, das da, das da, was machen wir gegen die fetten?
gegen die fetten brauchen wir ein bisschen was zum sprengsohren
das, das, das, das
das ist jetzt wichtig, dass wir
irgendwas haben, um die kaputt machen zu können
probieren wirs mal so
das video mit dem breitbandanschluss war traurig
ja ist es auch
wäre für dich nicht dein unity media business anschluss eine alternative
aber die haben auch nicht wirklich mehr upload
oder? also das letzte mal wo ich geguckt habe hatten die 20
ich glaube 20, 20, ab
und es wäre wirklich viel teurer unity media business
also es wäre für mich wirklich viel teurer
oh fuck, ich hab gar keine kartoffel bombe
es wäre viel teurer unity media business
also ich hab ja über unity media, hab ich ja im fernseher
internet und halt auch telefon, aber das telefon verwende ich nicht
und mit business gibt es dann zum beispiel kein fernseher
das müsste man dann wieder extra machen und so
ich würde wahrscheinlich das doppelte von jetzt unity media bezahlen
wenn ich ein business anschluss hole
wie kann man in bdo die guilden kriege meldung ausschalten
muss man in soundoption gucken
also ich glaube das geht da
ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube das geht da
wo man auch diese marketplace dinger ausschalten kann
vielleicht weiß es ja jemand hier im chat
mal gucken, dass es gleich kleine, große zombies kommen
also wir müssen die nächste reihe schnell kriegen
bugged rum seit letztem patch
kann ich mir vorstellen, was bugged bei bdo nicht, ich hab ihn so mal rum
also technisch ist bdo wirklich kein gutes game
das muss man nur sagen
da merkste, dass sehr vieles mit heißer nadel gestrickt ist
aber es muss ja auch ein recht kleines team sein
was kostet ein internet
also ich hab ja mittlerweile noch von unity media das was ich vorher die ganze zeit hatte
und halt jetzt bloß die telecom mit vdsl
also das ist jetzt nicht das was in zukunft kosten wird
ich werde das ein bisschen downgraden
weil ich muss keine 2 internet anschlüsse bezahlen, die ich dann brauche
ich glaube jetzt kostet unity media gerade 65 euro im monat
und telecom weiß ich gar nicht
aber es wird ja ein bisschen weniger werden
oh da ist so ein fettes fisch schon
auf, move dich, kein bock
kein bock
ich scroll gleich durch
ich frag mich, wird es manche Leute hinkriegen in 24 stunden live stream zu machen
das geht doch gar nicht ohne dass ihr dabei abkratzt
das sind wie die koreaner, die in ihren internet cafes
wo es da ab und zu mal alle 1-2 monaten mal eine meldung gibt, dass da wieder einer verdurstet ist
oder verhungert ist
oder was auch immer gestorben ist
beim spielen im internet café
im internet café
vdsl 100, telecom sind 45, ja kann sein, irgendwie so
das erste jahr ist glaube ich ein bisschen billiger
ich werde gucken, dass ich das, unity media werde ich jetzt aufs nötigste downgraden
was geht
und sobald unity media wieder ein besseres angebot hat, wird dann halt telecom down gecreated
wie kannst du nur die rein nicht einheitlich halten
brauche ich net, wow, oh, muss ich ja mal kurz aufpassen hier
fuck
mit half
alter
äh
der machts platt
egal, ich habe ja noch meinen reiniger hier und gleich auch wieder die chili, dann
oh nein, nein
jetzt, bam, perfekt
melone, jawoll, die geht ab, so was habe ich jetzt im chat überlesen, ich muss mal kurz scroll so an
als du den atlas mit der bandbreite aufgemacht hast, hast du die gebiete im osten was, äh gebiete gezeigt da wo mein dorf war, war mein dorf dabei, ja
es haben ein paar lustige, es haben ein paar leute geschrieben, dass ich genau das gezeigt habe wo sie wohnen
dabei habe ich nur irgendetwas, was ich gesehen habe, was ich gesehen habe, was ich gesehen habe, was ich gesehen habe
dabei, ja, siehst du nun einen plans for the tommys speedrunner, ja sieht man doch, eindeutig, ich bin grad 2 minuten über personal best
das ist ja schon im haus teilweise problematisch
aber ich glaube über längere strecken geht das nicht gescheit habe ich mich
ehrlich gesagt aber nicht damit beschäftigt man da ob man da was machen
könnte
so von melonen das da das da das da umgedreht das da das da melonen
weiß katapult muss sein beste
guck mal was da geht hast du eigentlich games dann quickstream verfolgt ein
bisschen habe ich gerade vorhin was zu erzählt dieses jahr weniger als sonst
weil mich das weil mir deshalb auch in die chat nicht gefallen hat
es geht ein bisschen schnell ich brauche ich brauche ich eine kartoffel bombe wird
das nix kann ich nicht schnell genug die sonnenblumen aufbauen falls ich
irgendwas überlesen habe schreibt es einfach noch mal ich bin da so ein
bisschen prägen auf irgendwie
guck mal der ritchie ist da hi kommst grad so zu einem ungründlichen
zeitpunkt ich hänge so halb halb vorm einpennen
irgendwie rum so die haben wir schon mal richtig gebaut nächste reihe hinterher
über sattelit leute das ist mist wird stehen nehmen leute hinterher über sattelit
ist krabb richtiger krabb master krabb also hinterher über sattelit ist
shit kriegen wir das jetzt gescheit ausgebaut vielleicht eine bombe das
problem an sattelit also an internet über sattelit ist so wie man das jetzt
am besten die müssen wir mal in die luft sprengen
das problem was sattelit über internet ist einfach der ping der ist einfach scheiße
boah wir brauchen ganz schön viel kohle um da melone zu bauen die melone sind
geil aber die melonen sind erst richtig gut wenn man noch ein bisschen mehr von
hat weil die machen splash damage
ein bisschen konzentrieren aber nicht kaputt machen egal soll das kaputt
fressen die wurscht
die die die die die die die brauchen ordentlich viele melonen dann dann geht das dann hauen die rein
machen die frontline auf
ja da ist es gut da hauen die melonen rein was ist echt
dann brauchen jetzt eins hier noch da brauchen wir eine melone da brauchen wir
eine melone und dann ist gut dann sind wir safe
ja das passt
der opa mit dem rasenmäher mit dem traktor guckt mir nach der runden chat an ich bin
gerade verwirrt blicken durch was ich machen soll eigentlich muss ich noch zwei melonen
bauen das ganze ist safe
da noch eine melone hinter ist gut easy easy life fucked letzte runde kommen
wahrscheinlich auch ein paar fette zombies
melone kann er pull the best ja ist so die teile sind geil es gibt auch später eine
eis variante von der freesie alles drum herum dazu muss man aber dumme minigames machen und
zeug züchten und so dass man die sich kaufen kann schon ein time sink
brauche ich gar nicht weil auch so alle um uns okay einer mit leiter aber gleich mal die leiter
löschen outplayed noob
moinder chef was der chef habe easy win wird doch zeit für die plans
also somis pro league
top ein level noch kommt der boss dann haben wir es geschafft
das ist dann mal ein zweites beendet das let's play innerhalb von zehn jahren wenn
man das mal netz play nennen kann ja aber ich meine es ist ich meine wir haben
gestartet spiel ist bis zum ende durch das ist eindeutig ist das ein let's play
anders kann man das nicht nennen
was war das erste black mesa alles erste was ich nach zwei jahren oder so was ich
was ich durch zwei jahre für gebraucht hat zum durchspielen zum durchspielen
mehr melonen ja stimmt ich kann eigentlich mehr melonen bauen ich habe genug sonne
brauche man zwar nicht aber melonen beste gibt es eigentlich die xen levels
mittlerweile für black mesa wie sieht es da eigentlich aus gibt es
mittlerweile xen levels
zum glück hat das sich gestarrt
die levels werden mit half life 3 release damit gehört da kommt man auch so vor
auch nicht was sie da so lange dran machen
ach man kann die story noch ein zweites mal durchspielen wusste ich gar nicht
dass sich das dann ändert
letztes level boss da war sogar kann ich mich noch dran erinnern da war sogar
verhältnismäßig schwierig im vergleich zum rest vom game
dave ist weg
und natürlich schon in merkwürdige minigame
musik ab
und ich muss passende sache einblenden für die musik passend
jetzt geht es weiter
den unkater bolt jawoll jetzt aufs marvel
scheiß ich habe kein kein eis ich habe kein pils mega knapp ultra knapp
muss ich mir aufheben unbedingt man muss gegen feuer muss man ein eispilz machen
und gegen eis muss man schillie machen wer hätte das gedacht auf und 1000
IQ der werde ich bestimmt nicht drauf gekommen hätte gesagt
so schwer ist da brauchst du auch nicht gewiss ich hab dir irgendwie schwierige
erinnerungen gehabt ist auch nicht warum
kann doch nix
so was muss man jetzt machen
bis ich alle
eine melone
ob so nicht
wie viel hat er noch leben eigentlich da unten
das war nicht der asi toni
bis ich alle das ist nicht der asi toni
bis ich alle das war auch aus der komischen rtl sendung
bis ich alle bis ich aus meinem leben oder irgendwie so wie das ging
ist das irgendwie aus der super nanny oder so
so eine scheiße merkt man sich da
ich habe zu wenig blumen dinger kübel
hätte man aufheben soll
ich brauche blumen dinger
das war eine melone in ruhe
jetzt können wir uns wieder aufbauen fettes ding gebascht
meine töpfe in ruhe
ja da müssen sie damage drauf machen die melone
jetzt auf halte oder kriegen wir den dauerner
oder hätte ich den pils ein bisschen später gesetzt
ja die können nicht die dinger
so
da